thank you he makes good film but he also  he's a director that knows how an actor  works and that's a joy for an actor I  mean he'll give you time and he really  knows where you're going and what if  where you have to go to get you know  what he wants  hey what's like to view this event today  well it's very exciting I feel like I'm  a part of a community that you know  those of us that are lucky enough to be  nominated for the Academy Awards are  gathering here to sort of celebrate  together  and that I saw Lupita upstairs and other  people that I've known so it's great  it's great fun kids and I'm just  wondering where some of those lines  especially the ones that when you were  visiting the graveyard did they let you  just go with that or with that written  in the screen that was all written it  was in the script I mean the first time  I read the script that scene was there  as we shot it thank you